salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
vous avez été très nombreux à adorer mon
top 5 des animaux immortels enfin
presque immortelle aujourd'hui j'ai
mieux à vous proposer le top 5 des
animaux les plus dangereux de la planète
vous allez voir ça va être mortel
[Musique]
pour commencer direction l'Afrique c'est
ici que vit notre première animal
dangereux et l'hippopotame
à première vue c'est un herbivore
d'apparence plutôt placide mais vous le
savez il ne faut jamais se fier aux
apparences en effet l’hippopotame est
une créature à éviter absolument bien
que ce ne soit pas un prédateur ce
mammifère se mit aquatique tu près de
500 personnes chaque année le match
qu'on puisse dire c'est que son gabarit
est impressionnant un malade peut
atteindre 5 mètres de longueur et peser
plus de 3 tonnes cela fait de
l'hippopotame l'un des mammifères les
plus lourds de la planète après
l'éléphant le rhinocéros ou la baleine
mais ce colosse à un point faible il est
doté d'une très mauvaise vue c'est un
gros handicap pour un herbivore en effet
ceci doivent être capables de repérer
leur prédateurs de très loin pour
compenser l'hippopotame a donc développé
un comportement agressif à l'égard de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
osent s'aventurer sur son territoire il
attaque sans sommation
et non son arme fatale une mâchoire
impressionnante qu'il peut ouvrir à
presque 180 degrés celle-ci est truffée
dedans aux dimensions hors normes et les
incisives inférieures des mâles peuvent
mesurer 30 à 40 cm quant au canine elle
ressemble à des défenses mesurant près
de 60 cm vous l'avez compris si elle se
referme sur sa victime elle n'a aucune
chance de s'en sortir vivant c'est dans
les rivières où il passe au plus clair
de son temps que l'hippopotame est le
plus dangereux on ne peut profondes il
est capable de charger à la vitesse de
30 km/h s'il est aussi rapide c'est
parce qu'en réalité il ne nage pas
vraiment il préfère galoper sur le fond
entre chaque enjambée le mastodonte
pousse sur ses pattes pour flotter dans
l'eau un peu comme un astronaute sur la
lune qui se déplace en micro-gravité
mais n'allez pas croire que sur la terre
ferme vous êtes plus en sécurité
l'animal a beau être lourd il n'en est
pas moins l'Est
observer il n'hésitera pas à vous
courser et n'aura aucune difficulté à
vous rattraper sur une courte distance
il peut atteindre la vitesse de 48 km/h
c'est plus que c'est une Bolt l'homme le
plus rapide du monde au top de sa
carrière le champion jamaïcain ne
dépassait pas
44,7 km/h alors si un jour vous croisez
un hippopotame courage fuyez avant qu'il
ne soit trop prêt qui tond le continent
africain direction l'Indonésie à l'autre
bout du monde c'est ici que se cache
l'une des créatures les plus effrayantes
de la planète le dragon de Komodo comme
son nom l'indique serait-il vit sur
l'île de Komodo on rencontre également
sur les îles voisines de Rinja Padar et
flores en réalité c'est un lézard c'est
même le plus grand lézard du monde il
peut dépasser les 3 mètres et peser plus
de 100 kg je vous rassure il ne crache
pas de feu mais mieux vaut l'éviter le
dragon de varan de Komodo est un
prédateur féroce qui ne fait pas de
quartier il dévore tout ce qui lui tombe
sous les griffes serpent petit lézard
oiseau mais aussi cochon singe chèvre
sert et même les énormes buffle d'eau
son appétit est insatiable pourtant à
première vue il n'a pas l'air si
dangereux regardez la gueule ouverte on
peut même croire qu'il n'a pas dedans
erreur celle-ci sont enfouies dans ces
gencives elle mesure environ 2,5 cm ça
ne semble pas énorme mais ne vous y
trompez pas elles sont redoutables c'est
dans son aussi efficaces que celle d'un
requin blanc très pointu avec des bords
dentelés elles sont de véritables
couteau acérées qui découpe les proies
sans aucune difficulté mais avant d'en
arriver là le dragon doit d'abord
débusquer ses victimes pour y parvenir
il se sert de sa langue bifide ce qui
signifie fendu
toutes les particules odorantes
présentes dans l'air elle agit comme un
radar une fois sa proie repérée leur
reptile se précipite sur elle en courant
il peut atteindre 20 km/h il peut même
nager si nécessaire mais ce qui fait de
notre gros lézard l'une des créatures
les plus dangereuses de la planète c'est
une arme secrète qui se niche dans sa
salive un redoutable venant lorsqu'il
mord sa proie le dragon de Komodo lui
inocule au passage un cocktail
empoisonné une fois dans le sang
celui-ci provoque une forte chute de la
pression artérielle qui se solde par un
arrêt cardiaque l'agonie peut durer des
heures mais notre varan à tous son temps
une fois morte il dévore sa proie en
deux temps trois mouvements son seul
point faible il n'est pas très endurant
le dragon se fatigue vite et passe le
plus clair de son temps
à lézarder dans la famille des reptiles
j'en connais un autre qui n'a aucune
pitié si vous croisez son chemin
la simple évocation de son nom donne le
frisson il s'agit du mamba noir un
serpent à venin considéré comme le plus
dangereux au monde il est si terrifiant
que le personnage principal du film Kill
Bill une tueuse interprétée par Uma
Thurman a été surnommée Black Mamba
mamba noir en anglais il doit son nom à
la coloration noire de sa cavité buccale
et non à la couleur de sa peau qui varie
du jaune vert au gris métallique
c'est le plus grand serpent du continent
africain sa taille peut varier 2 mètres
50 à plus de 4 mètres léger il est très
agile dans les arbres c'est toutefois au
sol qu'il est le plus à l'aise le mamba
est capable de se déplacer à la vitesse
de 23 km/h c'est aussi rapide qu'une
trottinette électrique mais son arme
fatale c'est bien sûr son venin une
seule morsure suffit à vous tuer en
quelques minutes la neurotoxine qui
contient appelée dans drotoxine agit
rapidement sur le système nerveux elle
provoque une paralysie des muscles
respiratoires la victime finit par
suffoquer puis elle meurt il suffit de
10 à 15 mg de venin pour tuer un homme
adulte je vous rassure le mamba
s'attaque rarement à nous lorsque ça se
produit c'est uniquement pour protéger
son territoire se redoutable serpent
préfère déguster de petits mammifères
comme les rongeurs c'est plus facile à
avaler nous restons en sur les bords du
Nil ici c'est le plus long fleuve du
continent et c'est aussi le territoire
d'un redoutable prédateur le crocodile
du Nil dans la grande famille des crocos
c'est l'un des plus dangereux il serait
responsable d'une centaine de morts par
an grand amateur de cherumaine il a la
très mauvaise habitude de roder à
proximité des villages à la moindre
occasion il surgit et ne vous laisse
aucune chance ce géant compte parmi les
plus grands reptiles du monde un mal
adulte peut mesurer jusqu'à 5 mètres de
long et peser jusqu'à 750 kg certains
spécimens sont carrément hors normes
c'était le cas le Gustave un crocodile
du Nil bien connu pour avoir terrorisé
le Burundi dans les années
90-2000 il dépassait les 6 mètres et
pesait plus d'une tonne à lui seul ce
bon Gustave aurait dévoré tenez-vous
bien plus de 300 personnes pour saisir
leur proie
c'est super prédateurs ont une bonne
secrète ils sont dotés d'une mâchoire
surpuissante sa force est estimée
environ 2 tonnes par centimètre carré
ces cinq fois plus que le lion est 30
fois plus que la morsure d'un être
humain pourtant ce monstre qui terrorise
les riverains du Nil ne pèse pas lourd
face à un autre prédateur bien plus
dangereux l'homme le braconnage la
déforestation et la pollution agricole
pourraient à court terme entraîner
l'extinction de l'espèce c'est un comble
car il fut un temps où le crocodile du
Nil était considéré comme un dieu par
les humains dans l'Égypte antique Sobek
le dieu à la tête de crocodile protéger
les hommes des crus et assurer la
fertilité des récoltes les Nubiens une
minorité unique présente en Egypte
continue d'ailleurs de vénérer ce grand
reptile au point que certains en font
même leur animal de compagnie
moi je me contenterai d'un chat ou d'un
chien notre cinquième et dernière animal
et sans aucun doute le plus redoutable
de tous en tout cas le plus meurtrier
chaque année il fait plus de 750 000
victimes dans le monde là je sens que je
pique votre curiosité et c'est bien
normal puisque ce tueur
ah non vous l'avez compris c'est le
moustique en tant que tel il n'a pas
l'apparence d'un assassin mais ces
petits insectes qui se nourrissent de
notre sang peuvent transmettre des
maladies mortelles comme le paludisme ou
la fièvre jaune l'un d'entre eux a
beaucoup fait parler de lui ces
dernières années c'est le fameux
moustique tigre originaire d'Asie la
haydès albopitudes trois maladies
potentiellement mortelles la dingue le
chikungunya ou encore le virus Zika
présent sur l'île de la Réunion depuis
pas mal d'années il a désormais envahi
l'Europe à cause des échanges
commerciaux en France métropolitaine il
est présent dans 67 départements en 2021
164 cas de dingue et trois cas de
chikungunya ont été déclarés pour
l'immense majorité il s'agit de cas
importer autrement dit des personnes qui
ont été infectées avant d'entrer sur le
territoire métropolitain malheureusement
pour l'heure on ne convient pas
l'éradiquer plusieurs pistes sont à
l'étude notamment une qui consiste à
relâcher dans la nature des malrendus
stériles des mâles qui ne piquent pas
seuls les femelles pompent notre sang
empêcheraient puisqu'ils sont stériles
la multiplication des moustiques si vous
avez trembler de plaisir devant ces
redoutables créatures n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce bleu ou à vous abonner à
la chaîne et surtout faites moi la liste
de vos envies pour les prochaines vidéos
nous les lisons toutes
à bientôt chers épicurieuses et chers
épicurieux
[Musique]